the chancellor has coming back early
from the IMF meetings in Washington what
do you make of that I think it's the
right thing to do because it does appear
that there are some serious discussions
going on now about possibly rowing back
on some of the tax commitments which I
think would be the right thing to do at
this moment and I think he will want to
be in the room as those discussions
occur so I think coming back early is
the right thing for him to do what do
you understand is being discussed well I
I think what will be on the table will
be particularly corporation tax the the
the the changes there the freeze
incorporation tax that was proposed
which is a big part of the remaining
elements of the package that haven't
gone through the House of Commons it's
about 18 billion pounds worth I think
that and other measures possibly rowing
back from that because as the ifs has
said there's about a 62 billion pound
hole in the public finances and these
kind of moods could probably fill 18 20
billion pounds worth of that and I think
send a very important all to the market
about fiscal credibility if the if they
did scrap that Rising corporation tax or
they reversed that commitment yes would
that be enough to calm the markets do
you think I think it's already priced in
so I think the markets have probably
settled a little bit on the expectation
that they will be going ahead now with
corporation tax increases so the problem
then becomes if they don't do it of
course they might get an adverse
reaction from the market so I think
they're kind of in a bit of a bind on
this one but I think overall in terms of
resetting the relationship with the
markets which is a fundamentally
important thing to do which says
knock-on consequence for where interest
rates went wind up for example it's the
right thing to do at the moment and how
soon because we heard from Greg hands
who is here sitting where you're sitting
now a little bit earlier on and causing
last night in Washington both saying
just wait we'll have details coming out
on the 31st of October you'll learn more
then can the markets wait that long well
we still need to have the the plan that
the chancellor will come forward with on
the 31st and alongside it the office of
budget responsibility which is the
independent forecaster coming forward
with its forecast so that must still
happen but I think what needs to happen
earlier than that is this rowing back on
some of these unfunded tax commitments
and that's something that really
announced your question we need to see
as soon as possible because clearly if
it is going to help steady the markets
why would you delay you would want to
come forward with it pretty quickly
today yep today or maybe first thing on
Monday we're fortunate that we've got a
weekend
intervening but the earliest possible
opportunity so would you be satisfied if
they announced either today on Monday a
change to their plans on corporation tax
would you be satisfied they've done
enough I I think the markets will
probably view that as a very significant
step towards fiscal credibility and I
think will be substantially reassured
and I think it would be the right thing
to do fiscal credibility what about
political credibility this is would
really under mine quasi quaten's
Authority wouldn't it there's no easy
solution to this all the options are
difficult it's a question of finding the
option uh that that is the best of a lot
of difficult options and I think the row
back would be the right approach now
you're right of course then the cry is
another U-turn and that in itself is
damaging but I think the alternative of
not doing it would be more damaging but
what would it mean for him personally
and for his job could he hang on as
Chancellor if he's reversed two key
planks of his mini budget so I think
what the Parliamentary party has got to
do is take a deep breath stay calm give
him that space to do whatever he's going
to do in the next 48 hours or so on the
tax front give him the space to come
forward with that plan at the end of the
month of the obr forecast in the hope
and the expectation that he gets it
right that we get a reset with the
markets and then we can start to have a
platform on which the government can
rebuild now nobody's going to say that
that's going to be easy but none of the
alternative routes to rebuilding are
going to be easy either and I do think
the Parliamentary party now needs to
give the chancellor that bit of extra
space now do you think they will do you
think he's safe in his job
um I certainly hope so I mean I I sense
having spent a bit of time in
Westminster this week There's of course
we've been away prior to that with
recess so there's clearly a very deep
level of satisfaction dissatisfaction
and concern amongst conservative members
of parliament to the degree to which is
that translating into a very organized
set of activities I'm not so sure at
this point but as I say I think now is
the time just to hold back take a deep
breath stay calm and just wait to hear
what the chancellor has to tell us
shortly and what he comes forward with
in what is just 18 days away his
fortunes are very closely tied to list
trusses surely this was her vision that
he's been acting out or he's put forward
in the mini budget if he's vulnerable
this trust is vulnerable isn't she I I
think that the entire conservative party
is vulnerable at the moment nobody can
be in a position where you're 20 30
points behind the labor party an
extraordinary polling position to be in
and not feel very vulnerable I think
anybody even with an apparently safe
conservative seat with a big majority
will be thinking very carefully about
where we're going so I think in that
sense we are really all in this together
and as I say I think we need to stay
calm for a bit give him a bit of space
and hopefully come forward with
something that we can build on and do
you still want to win the job by
Christmas I do because I you know I I
want the primers to succeed I want the
chance to succeed because if we can do
that then the country will succeed okay
Mel stride we appreciate your time
thanks very much thank you